dans un peu plus d'un an Paris
accueillera les Jeux Olympiques 2024 les
Jeux Olympiques seront un élément dans
la relance économique de Paris de
l'Île-de-France et de la France
censé être une grande opportunité pour
la France ont aujourd'hui menacées en
cause la réforme des retraites
contestées par de nombreux Français
cette réforme est-elle acceptée
à l'évidence non depuis la promulgation
de cette loi un hashtag a fait son
apparition sur les réseaux sociaux et a
été relayé massivement pas de retrait
pas de Jo pas de retrait pas de Jo entre
grève blocages et manifestations
plusieurs personnes prévoient de
perturber l'événement en l'absence d'un
retrait de la réforme des retraites une
menace choc qui a même fait réagir la
ministre des Sports Amélie où est
dacastéra c'est des jeux des Français
c'est en aucun cas les jeux de l'État en
aucun cas les jeux du gouvernement alors
réforme
français les JO 2024 prévus à Paris
pourront-ils avoir lieu
[Musique]
vous comprenez quand en pleine en pleine
réforme des retraites mais bon on était
voté que certains fassent un chantage
aux Jeux Olympiques
est-ce que vous comprenez cette façon de
se positionner est-ce que est-ce que
voilà est-ce que on doit
perturber les JO sous prétexte que la
loi pour les retraites est passé il faut
vraiment faire une trêve et sur on a
déjà assez la honte alors dans tous les
pays des autres pays j'espère vraiment
les gens vont être appelés à la raison
vous rendez compte qu'il y a un appel en
ce moment parce que on cherche beaucoup
de bénévoles par exemple pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture il y a des choses
qui circulent sur les réseaux sociaux
pour que les gens s'engagent comme
bénévoles et ne viennent pas le jour de
cérémonie pour [__] en l'air la
cérémonie d'ouverture moi je trouve ça
scandaleux après je il y a plein de
choses que fait le gouvernement que je
trouve scandaleuse mais là il faut
arrêter il faut il faut plus qu'on soit
la ministre a bien parlé elle a dit
c'est pas c'est pas ça qu'il faut
attaquer c'est pas représentatif en gros
de l'État ou des décisions JO c'est
rassembleur c'est c'est le monde c'est
la France donc c'est rassemble pas des
sport et même des sportifs français de
prendre position comme cet effet à une
autre époque bien sûr on peut aussi
manifester avec un brassard exactement
oui madame oui globalement je trouve
qu'il ne faut pas se servir de des
événements sportifs comme un message
politique voilà je trouve que le sport
doit rester apolitique donc voilà ça
c'est mon idée c'est mon vous recevriez
les Athus non oui oui
je l'ai déjà dit c'est une position
minoritaire mais moi aucun sportif russe
ne devrait participer
à ce soir
tout ce que vous voulez en tennis
ostensiblement qu'ils sont contre ils le
déclare publique
contre les discriminations etc
en réalité en réalité moi je comprends
que des gens sans donner mon avis sur la
réforme des retraites je comprends que
des gens qui on est qui en ont marre qui
ont du mal à se faire entendre on voit
voilà le président qui va au contact
mais mais sans sans aller voir les
manifestants etc qu'ils essaient de
trouver des solutions annexes pour se
faire entendre je discutais hier avec un
conducteur de métro qui m'exbo vous
prenez le métro comment alors non mais
j'ai un ami qui conducteur de métro qui
m'expliquait qu'ils sont en train de
monter une fronde
qui va peut-être bloquer les JO parce
qu'ils veulent plus voilà
ils disent qu'en fait déjà le service
n'est pas normal pour les pour les pour
les pour les Français en temps normal et
que et que là il ne voit pas comment
avec le manque de personnel ou avec des
salaires qui sont un peu trop faibles
comment ils vont réussir à assurer le
transport avec un événement
supplémentaire et il y a un très gros
test qui arrive c'est la Coupe du monde
de rugby qui aura lieu en France à la
rentrée et là déjà ça va être un énorme
test pour savoir si Paris est capable
d'organiser un événement planétaire
comme celui-ci
c'est un sujet compliqué non je pense
pas que ce soit bien de prendre en otage
une cérémonie et des athlètes etc en
même temps est-ce que c'était vraiment
est-ce que c'est le bon moment pour
avoir des JO le papier
les mouvements sociaux qu'on a en ce
moment je suis désolé c'est assez inédit
on est dans un contexte explosif je
comprends que les gens soient désespérés
et et essaie de de d'avoir recours à
tout parce qu'il y a pas de dialogue en
fait
c'est le sujet des Jeux Olympiques
le problème c'est le manque de dialogue
le manque de dialogue on impose des
choses et donc les gens finissent par
être désespéré mais n'importe quoi qu'il
arrive de toute façon ça n'ira pas je
pense que quoi qu'il arrive ne se trompe
pas plus entendu que ce qu'ils le sont
maintenant et pour le coup la moyenne
image quand même assez négative à
l'étranger il va y avoir un vrai focus
sur la France pendant les JO et je pense
que c'est vraiment le moment de pouvoir
aussi montrer une autre image que celle
qu'on a à présent
Laurent Berger qui a dit hors de
question de faire de ce type de menace
oui ce type d'action vous voyez donc il
y a une espèce de conscience
non mais on peut comprendre le désespoir
ça c'est sûr et que ce soit un coup
voilà une espèce de coup d'action mais
faut pas se tromper c'est pas la bonne
cible ça va desservir encore une fois la
cause c'est comme voilà d'aller siéger
chez LVMH c'est pareil c'est la cible
est pas bonne le message
je suis d'accord plus quoi faire moi
j'adore être le gouvernement voilà
mettre ses couilles sur la table et
disent ok on va écouter syndicalistes et
on va trouver une réponse c'est pas le
cas les gens dans une position
désespérée il se passe des bêtises et
voilà c'est c'est vrai que les gens font
des choses comme tu dis tout les
victimes de tout ça ça sera pas ça sera
pas l'état ça sera pas le gouvernement
ça va être les gens qui veulent aller
voir qui veulent aller voir un spectacle
qui est magnifique que pour une fois on
a la chance d'avoir en France les
économistes ont de l'argent ça coûte un
blinde chacun fait ce qui veut son
argent
c'est une fortune mais c'est peut-être
le plaisir c'est peut-être le plaisir
ultime pour qu'il y a des bordel
je suis désolé je suis gêné pour toi que
ta ligne autant de conneries dans une
seule émission
le fait d'empêcher les athlètes si tu
empêche les trucs alors tu demandes à
tous les autres la tête comment il se
positionnement russe ou truc le mien
parce qu'il y a plein d'athlètes qui
sont pas russes le foot les empêche ils
ne jouent plus au foot le basket les
baskets
négatives et d'ailleurs le CIO le CIO
comment tu fais le CIO voudrait les
réintégrer potentiellement mais il y a
plein de français c'est dégueulasse
d'horizon politique d'hiver qui commence
à dire pas de sportif russe à Paris donc
ça va faire une immense polémique
qui se sont positionnés officiellement
pour Poutine qui soit exclu bien sûr
qui revient à la cérémonie d'ouverture
c'est quand même les JO le seul moment
où chaque pays des fils avec son drapeau
ce qui défileront ne seront pas sous le
drapeau russe ce sera sous bannière
neutre potentiellement s'il y en a voilà
et le drapeau biélorus il y en aura pas
la bannière je suis d'accord
allez Allez la France
toutes les deux France qui va être
bloqué les travaux
à avoir des places pour pouvoir les
belles disciplines
ça suffit là là on est en train de
glisser vers le bal de la rue